foreign
[Music]
I didn't recommend locking anything down
and the record will show Neil that we
didn't recommend shutting everything
down I recommended to the president that
we shut the country down they will keep
getting things wrong but a certain set
of people will keep following the crumbs
that they are laying out behind them as
you can see Whoopi is not here she has
covid
whoopee has covered
and I took an acting class actually
about 15 years ago and I can tell you
this for sure actors are morons and at
the University of Michigan students
testing covid positive must need their
dorms for five days and live in the
community if you have a kid at a college
who's got coveted let him spread it with
a bunch of young healthy people and
maybe they'll have the sniffles for a
little bit like they would with the flu
you don't send them to Grandma's house
we will be encouraging as I have said
before Americans to get their updated
covid-19 vaccine no no I'm not getting
the covid vaccine I'm not getting the
flu shot and you should be embarrassed
lady to even have that job Democrats and
Republicans agree buying this tool the
thing that the president is able to do
is deliver and guess what he beats them
every time because he has his finger on
the pulse of what it is that the
American people need the man barely has
a pulse what are we doing I think both
Trump and Bin are too old I think there
should I don't think you should be able
to be that old to be president but I
think Trump
more aware but for Tucker to say I agree
100 neither one of these guys should be
running late because they're too old
that's pretty powerful
thank you
all right people I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Reuben report it is September 7th
2023 we are live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals share subscribe tap
that notification Bell if you have not
and join us for a post game wrap up at
reubenreport.locals.com and actually
after we do a couple stories today uh
covid it's back baby well it's as back
as you want it to be if you wanted to be
back it's back if you don't want it to
be back it's not back that's on you a
couple stories today and then we will be
doing a locals Community Q a uh
questions are all over the map this week
and if you want to get a question in on
the Fly uh if you join us on locals you
can do that right now uh but you know
yesterday I was talking about sort of
the media the way the media confuses
everybody on every topic and how this
certain set of people as I just said in
that recap there they they follow the
crumbs no matter how many times at the
end of the trail they realize oh this
was a mistake this was wrong this was a
lie they lied us into this war they
light us into wearing masks they light
us into getting injected they lied to us
about the election whatever it might be
a certain set of people keep following
that trail and I think what we've got to
do is keep converting the people who are
on the trail going something ain't right
here what are we gonna do about that so
we're going to be talking about some of
the mainstream media coverage of the
covid Resurgence because Whoopi Goldberg
has covid and she did not go to the
studio at the view but she did send in a
video and then we're going to also cover
the I mean the view you know I had to
say I designed yesterday we're going to
cover a couple of the main points that
DeSantis and I hit uh yesterday
afternoon but the view also gave some of
their presidential analysis and these
ladies they should be doing if it was
the view from the nut house then it
would make more sense you know what I
mean it's like I always used to say
about Brian stelter on on on reliable
sources if they would have just called
it unreliable sources now you gotta show
and if they called it the view from The
Nut House now you gotta show anyway
we're going to cover the view
covid presidential analysis and then I
want to recap a bit of my interview uh
with DeSantis which seems to be catching
fire on Twitter right now and
did the guy lie did the guy say anything
that was untrue did he lay out a vision
did he make fun of anybody did he call
anybody names like there is a way out of
this we're just going to decide
collectively if we actually want out or
we want more we will decide all right
let's talk about Birch gold and then
we'll get to it guys uh Congress once
again allowed itself to be pushed into
appeasing the administration raising the
debt ceiling for the 79th time Paving
the way for continued Reckless spending
and further devaluation of the dollar as
our national debt continues to Skyrocket
how are you protecting your savings
Times Like These are a great reminder to
diversify a portion of your savings into
gold and you can do that with the help
of Birch gold and here's the easiest way
to do it Birch gold will help you
convert an existing Ira or 401K into an
IRA in Gold you don't pay a penny out of
pocket and as bricks Brazil Russia India
China and South Africa band together
against the dollar more and more central
banks are diversifying and you know what
they're buying
you guessed it
follow their lead guys visit
birchgold.com Dave for your free info
kit on gold there's no obligation just
information they've got an A plus rating
with the Better Business Bureau and
happy and thousands of happy customers
uh Birch gold can help protect your
savings too visit birchgold.com Dave
take action today all right here we go
people because yes covet is back if you
want it to be back in your life people
do occasionally get sick and before
covid you'd get the sniffles take a day
off and go back but now we quarantined
we lock ourselves up we inject ourselves
this stuff we put messages on Twitter
saying we're so happy that we're
vaccinated even though we're sick
etc etc so anyway Whoopi's got the the
kovid she sent in a pre-recorded message
to the ladies of The View
but anyway
um
it's in a little video for
bite of everything you've heard and let
me just make sure you all know that it's
actually me
say it's me uh I am not a burning man I
am not still in Italy I am not you know
doing stuff I'm not trying to change the
outcome of the election I just I have
called it and just have Colvin I'm still
testing positive apparently uh I have to
have a clear test before I can come back
so it might be a couple of days but you
know I'm really thrilled to see the
beautiful new desk I'm really thrilled
to see all the beautiful women you girls
look great and uh
you know I can't wait to get back and
hang out but in until then it's me in my
mask
and I'm sort of confined to my room
I've never been sent to my room like
this in my in my at this age but I've
been confined to my room but I just
wanted to say hi and let everybody know
that uh
I'll be there as soon as I can and I'm
sending you all great love and can't
wait to get back to our favorite place
to view
can I just tell you
Whoopi Goldberg as we know likes
electric heated toilets the chance of
her being a burning man is silk
Whoopi on the toilet is not something I
needed to know about this morning uh
there's so much here first off we
googled it Whoopi's worth a cool 60 mil
that's at least what the internet's
telling us what what room is she in
there right like she looks like she's
staying at a hostel that's number one
but okay Whoopi that's just fine the
absurdity of the Mask she's sitting
alone in a room supposedly in her house
she's touching the mask first off she's
alone in the room why would you be
wearing a mask if you're alone in a room
masks don't work we also know that then
she takes the mask down she's touching
the mask first then she takes the mask
down to talk to the like it's all so
stupid it's such ridiculous theater and
again you might go Dave I know it's
ridiculous theater but these brainwashed
NPCs non-playable characters we must
save them that is the mission of the
good sane people the few of us the
rebels that are left we must someone's
watching that oh poor whoopee she's
wearing a mask up in her room and she's
so sad
but okay fine covid that all that other
stuff and as you know Dr Jill Biden who
is a doctor of sorts of sorts uh she
also has covid despite her having kovid
Joe Biden's been wandering around the
White House without a mask even though
they said he would mask and follow CDC
guidelines okay you get all the BS on
that let's continue with the view uh
because then they started talking about
California the presidential race and oh
God here we we are back it's September
we're back go
but the question is who would you put in
there if Biden decides to get out of the
race for some whatever reason he comes
up with well I don't think he's going to
get out don't answer like a republican
it's not going to happen but I would
hope that the Democrat the Democratic
party would uh rally around the vice
president Kamala Harris the way they've
rallied around Joe Biden but if not I
think Gavin Newsom is uh he's he's
responsible for one of the largest
economies in our country
is in trouble all the time with a lot of
homeless and a lot of problems but they
have a lot of good programs when it
comes to climate change they have great
they have great programs in terms of job
opportunity they're doing uh they have
great programs in terms of housing
they're addressing that is
uh there is so much there my pen almost
broke in the middle of that okay so
first off uh I want to give joy Bae our
credit I try to give credit where credit
is due
uh Sonny says Gavin Newsom California
it's great he should be president
basically right because somehow Kamala
is not going to end up president like
it's just not going to happen the
country will not Rally around her the
Democrats will not Rally around her the
only way they rally around her is if
they realize she is just full on 100
percent hermetically sealed puppet right
like that's the only way no one is
handing the nuclear codes to this woman
it's already hilarious or scary as if
that that Joe's got him in the first
place but putting aside Kamala for a sec
when when Sonny says Gavin do some Joy
has like a moment of Sanity that
California does have problems economic
problems and it has homeless problems
well I can't I can't believe it should
we send Joy something we should send Joy
a bottle of something whatever she's
drinking it's I feel like she's a white
wine spritzer lady uh she actually
addresses that and then and then Sonny
what does she say well Gavin newsom's
responsible for one of the largest
economies which he has as tanked
California basically has the highest
taxes in the country it's always
fighting with New York on who's going to
have higher taxes uh basically the most
regulation in the country so small
businesses don't want to start there
because you have to pay all of this
money to get your licenses to if you
want to build a home you have all of
these other regulations there's all of
this extra stuff that makes you as a
person who wants to be functional and
productive it makes your life basically
a living hell to accomplish anything so
okay they have a big economy because
California was the American dream Gavin
Newsom has been a large part of
destroying that thus for three straight
years now for the first time ever
California as you guys know has had a
net loss of population I've got four of
the people in this room right now who
all move to the free state of Florida
eventually also says that California has
great policies related to climate which
is just such a absolute
farce at every level putting aside that
the entire climate conversation is
complete nonsense the Earth is going to
be okay guys it really is the idea that
California or Gavin Newsom that they are
doing anything to save the environment
you know when we lived in California we
lived in L.A and occasionally it would
rain fire once or twice a year it would
literally rain fire and there would be
massive fires burning all over the place
why didn't Gavin Newsom Stop Those fires
why doesn't Gavin Newsom stop the the
earthquakes I mean it's just such BS and
the idea that even if you 100
believed in man-made climate change that
Gavin Newsom could fix it my God just
incredible but it continues because uh
the ladies they not they weren't all
fully satisfied with the Gavin Newsom
answer so there must be somewhat better
in the party than Gavin Newsom
I think him I still think Pete
butterjudge is really great whenever
I've seen him speak would the country
put a gay president in the game that's
my that's not a concern I don't care
he's the best one
he's really great
homophobic incredible analysis by the
blonde there nobody knows her name does
anyone know her name and when we play
clips of The View every day nobody knows
her name literally nobody knows um it
doesn't even matter but he's just great
I hear him talking he's just great
first off the gay thing is nobody cares
literally nobody cares anymore he's
married to a dude big deal if he was a
great Transportation secretary let's say
our infrastructure was just being
rebuilt at an incredible rate right now
when things like the the horrific
disaster in East Palestine happened that
the government got in there and cleaned
up real quick or whatever's still going
on in Maui as we speak the disaster over
there from the fire it's like if the
government was functional and this guy
was in charge of a lot of things and
doing it well then maybe there would be
a case maybe there would be a case to be
made but basically what she's saying is
he's gay he's gay and I like him when he
speaks that's not that does not make you
you know what Connor you know what they
did they put her name on the screen for
me I'm not even going to read it now I
know what her name is okay that's just
fine nobody needs to know her name
somehow she's like a completely erasable
character on that ridiculous program I'm
not even going to say it does not matter
anyway the point is Biden is not running
the show and it's just a matter of how
long can they string them along nobody
believes in Kamala Harris Gavin Newsom
is an evil lizard person Pete is gay
are there better options are there
better options well I actually think
there are so now let's talk about
obviously the guy that I think is the
best option and I think he made quite a
case for it uh on this program yesterday
I had Governor DeSantis on uh we were
supposed to do it here in person in
Miami of course we had hurricane idalia
yes last week in Florida got him stuck
up in Tallahassee the hurricane actually
hit Tallahassee quite intensely but it
hit mostly the west coast and then
Northern Florida so they they had to
cancel the trip but they did give us the
time on Skype and I tried to do the
interview a little bit differently with
him because I didn't think it would
behoove either one of us just to talk
about how great Florida is and all the
stuff that you guys know and I know and
everything else I wanted to talk about
the strategy of the campaign I wanted to
talk about how you get Maga supporters
and how you go after Trump properly and
and all of those things and I'm glad to
see that the reaction has been so
effective so we're just gonna play three
clips from that and of course you can
watch the the full thing on Rumble and
locals and YouTube right now uh here's
part one or here's the first portion
when I asked him and I think maybe this
was the most important question
how do you get the Maga base one way or
another whether whether Trump drops out
stays in is in jail is indicted blah
blah blah how do you convince That Base
that you're actually the guy
well nobody in in the United States in
the Republican party has delivered more
on America First policies and principles
than me if you look at immigration
illegal immigration we've banned
Sanctuary cities we've cracked down on
human smuggling we even sent illegal
aliens to beautiful Martha's Vineyard uh
and so we've put our money where our
mouth is you talk about things like
China we've banned the purchase of land
by the CCP and its Affiliates in our
state we got rid of things like
Confucius institutes and we crack down
on their influence of universities you
look at what we've done for expand
second amendment rights with
constitutional carry look at what we've
done to fight against the woke agenda
whether it's fighting Disney involving
education or fighting this ESG movement
which is really bad uh for our economy
and for American families the way
they're going after domestic energy
production you want to talk about
draining the swamp there's one guy in
this entire country that's ever
overtaken action against soros-backed
prosecutors and that's me and we've
removed two of them from office in the
last year year and a half who were not
following the law and were putting their
political agenda over Public Safety I
cleared out the election supervisors in
South Florida when I became Governor
we've banned Zucker bucks we've banned
ballot harvesting we have Universal
voter ID and we even have an election
crimes task force police force in state
government which which prosecutes voter
fraud so we have the best election
Integrity in the entire country so I
think in terms of delivering on these
things nobody's delivered more than I
have and everything I promised the
voters I I would do I've delivered on
and exceeded those promises and so
you've got a guy like me going in there
you know you'll have two terms of
somebody uh that that the people in
Washington do not want to see up there
the corporate press does not want to see
me up there and the Democrats don't want
to see me up there because they realize
I don't just say this stuff in a
campaign season when I tell you I'm
going to do something I follow through
and I do it
all right look I I know that many of you
watching this show prefer Trump over to
santis many of you watching this show
preferred Santa's over Trump I have no
doubt that some of you prefer the backup
no doubt some of you prefer Nikki etc
etc no doubt that some of you are
Democrats some of you are not going to
vote some of you don't live in this
country it's all good
what I want to point out there is that I
gave him the chance to talk to the Trump
people specifically that base that we're
always told that unmovable base uh he
did not mock them nor belittle them or
anything else but he just laid out I
just started bulleting it out myself as
he was as he was doing this right just
listen to what he just said off the top
of his head and tell me if are there any
lies here are there are there any
untruths are there any unconfusions
immigration Sanctuary cities China's
Second Amendment fighting the woke
Disney education ESG firing Soros DA's
voter ID does what he promises you'll
get two terms of it and he is the guy
that the corporate press and the Dems
fear the most every single word of that
was true does that matter to you you
have to decide that you have to decide
that who can accomplish the things that
you believe in that you want government
to do I know you don't want government
to do that much but who's the guy that
you think can accomplish it who's the
guy that you think can bring in new
voters bring in those disaffected
liberals I'm always talking about create
a new coalition
I'll let you decide that uh we did talk
a bit more about Trump and I asked
DeSantis if he thought Trump should
attend the next debate
yeah I mean look I think he owes it to
the to the public to debate I think the
the idea that he's entitled to be
nominated is absurd I think that there's
a lot of questions that he needs to
answer uh both about how he would win
the election uh but also about some of
the decisions that he made as president
you pointed out the fauci and then there
are others uh so I think he should do it
he probably won't do it uh and that's
fine I'm going to be there regardless I
do think you're going to see a smaller
stage because I think some of those
folks aren't going to qualify for this
next round and look my thing is is you
know it's far be it for me to tell
anyone who to run or not run but uh you
either have a path or you don't and if
you don't have a path then we should
focus on the candidates you know that
have a that have a conceivable shot at
this um I will say though being on that
stage I think one of the reasons why
um you know I wasn't necessarily the
target as much as people thought is I
have a record of success I've done the
things that people are talking about
that we need to do for this country
country in Florida across the board and
so I'm armed with the ability to say
that I've done it and also to point out
you know whatever shortcomings would be
from somebody that's lobbying a grenade
my way so I'm prepared to do however it
shakes out but if it's just me and I get
something I want to look into the camera
and tell people my vision of how to
reverse this country's decline beat
Biden and get us on a better path and
and I think we all know we need to do
that I'm the one guy that has a record
of showing how it can be done with how
we've transformed Florida you guys know
how I always say the thing about how
when you're listening to someone tell
the truth it's just kind of easy to
listen to like you can sit back you can
breathe you can relax it's obvious and
and all of that was true I want to make
two points on this uh you know this line
about how he would win meaning Trump has
to explain how he would win this is a
major major point if Trump believes and
he does he keeps repeatedly saying it
that the last election was stolen well
you might say I'm the guy who's going to
drain the swamp and I'm the guy who they
stole the election from and you can say
all of that stuff you can rile up that
base and all of that you can convince
everyone the election was stolen and I I
don't even have to offer an opinion on
that but if that is your argument then
the second piece of your argument has to
be and here's how I will stop them from
doing it again but as far as I know
Trump has done literally nothing on that
so if you if you absolutely love Trump
and again the country was better under
him if he is the nominee I'm gonna vote
for him I don't think he's profoundly
evil I don't have TDS I've basically
broken bread with the guy all of that
stuff that you know but in if he can't
lay out oh that they stole it for me
last time I'm just going to do it all
over again the exact same way if he
can't explain how that won't happen
again that's a bit of a flaw so you
really need to think about that then I
want to address one other thing about
debating specifically because DeSantis
is saying yeah he should debate he
probably won't you know at the uh at the
first debate in Milwaukee when we did
our post game show with Glenn Greenwald
and Michael malice and Jordan Peterson
Jordan said something that I think
really hit the nail on the head he said
in a healthy democracy Donald Trump and
Joe Biden would both be debating now I
see a lot of trump people right now
going well look at these National polls
and he's up by 50 points and he can only
lose there's no win in it for him so he
shouldn't have to now that at a purely
tactical strategic level if you only
think that all of this is a game and
it's only about like winning in the most
sort of uh narrow sense of the word then
I suppose Trump should not debate right
because I guess yes he could get on that
debate stage and DeSantis would go right
at him and Nikki would probably go right
Adam and Pence might go right out of
Vivek won't because he's he's sort of
his pet at the moment but he might take
some fire but the point is in a truly
healthy democracy as Jordan said we
would be debating ideas in a better way
right Trump wouldn't be afraid of
Defending his record saying here are the
few mistakes that I made you know he
still won't admit he really made made
any mistakes around kovid and Joe Biden
would be willing to debate say RFK Jr or
someone else who might be on the
Democrat side of things again I get that
strategically if you only care about
winning in that sense then then it isn't
the best way but if we were really a
serious country if we were really a
group of mature people willing to defend
our ideas willing to lay out a vision
and all of those things and I don't
really think that's what Trump is
anymore he was great as the Insurgent
but I I don't think he has fully thought
through what's going on here and I think
DeSantis sees that and my hope is over
the next couple months more and more
people will see that maybe I wrong all
right well you fight for what you
believe in I want to address one other
thing in that interview because you know
a lot of people
especially the drum base have not been
happy with DeSantis because a few months
back when Tucker was still on Fox Tucker
asked for a statement from all of the
the candidates this was before DeSantis
had even announced but from all of the
potential candidates on the Republican
side for a statement on their position
on Ukraine DeSantis gave a fairly strong
statement that sounded very isolationist
and then it seems to be or at least the
media narrative on it is that he's
walked it back of it so I asked him that
exact question
I was asked after that whether I thought
Putin was a good guy and I said of
course not but that doesn't mean that we
should be writing a blank check uh with
no concept of what our interests are or
what the victory is so we've been pretty
consistent actually on all this uh we
need to end this war no blank check
Europe needs to step up uh and anything
we do should be in America's national
interest you don't subcontract out your
national interests to other countries
and I don't think it's been in our
interest to be sending money to pay
pensions for Ukrainian bureaucrats and
salaries for Ukrainian bureaucrats so
what I would do as president I would use
the leverage that we have available to
us to bring the conflict to an end in a
way that this isn't going to continue to
be an issue
all right I think that was clean and
clear we could the three sentences end
this war no blank check everything
should be in America's interest simple
clean blah blah blah now you can have a
million follow-up questions on that
which you should have for all of the
candidates how are you going to do it
how quickly are you going to do it what
if Russia incurs you know has more of an
incursion into Ukraine we can discuss
all of that but I think that was clean
and clear and hopefully that satisfies a
little bit of some of the let's say
confusion that that perhaps the base was
having around that I know it will not
satisfy everybody is what it is but I
would really welcome all of you to uh
watch the full interview it's 22 minutes
if you're on the fence about this thing
if you're not sure if you think that
somehow because because Trump has
unfortunately lied so much about this
guy if you think he Soros backed even
though as he pointed out he's fired two
Soros DA's if you think he's in it with
Paul Ryan and whatever it's like watch
the interview and tell me what you think
see if there was anything that you think
is an outright live I'll gladly gladly
address it and we shall go from there
and also on Twitter we have a whole
bunch of the clips up if you want to
grab them real quick let's get to the
Community Q a but real quick I want to
talk to you about gravity defy your
shoes guys how much is it worth to not
feel pain with every step you take from
walking the dog to running the kids from
school to practice it takes a toll well
you need to check out gravity to Fire
Shoes whether you're wearing them on the
job or to get your daily step count up
these gravity to fire shoes are
revolutionary walking and running in
normal shoes creates shock waves that
course through your feet knees and hips
forcing the body to absorb as much as a
thousand pounds of harmful impact with
every step gravity to fire shoes are
clinically shown to relieve knee pain in
a double-blind study by Olive View UCLA
Medical Center and published in the
Journal of the American podiatric
Medical Association participants
experienced 85 percent less knee pain
it's the most powerful shock absorbs an
absorption system put into a shoe I'm
using them when I'm doing cardio and as
you know I've torn ACL in my left knee
so here's the deal guys try a pair for
60 days and experience the difference
they can make in your life buy a pair
today and save 15 with free returns and
easy exchanges you'll have nothing to
lose visit gravity to fire.com use code
Reuben for 15 off your first order test
a pair risk free and experience the
difference in your life gravity to
fire.com gravitydefire.com code Reuben
and now back to me all right let's get
to it a
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q a
Janine says hey did you get a chance to
speak with Larry Elder at the debate it
sounded like the RNC was going out of
their way to exclude him so wrong so you
know one of my great disappointments
that day and it happened almost
immediately so think about it we got
into Milwaukee on August 22nd the night
before now remember I still knew nothing
about the debate I didn't know who was
in who was out I didn't know if Trump
was going to be there I'm going through
the airport people are saying hi to me
I'm making sure I don't find out any
information right all of that we get
then in the morning
to the site uh where you know to The
Venue where the debate is and Rumble had
their Studio outside were out there and
it's early in the day this is we got
there I don't know oh well we did our
comeback show at 11 A.M Eastern which
was 10 a.m Eastern because they're in
central time but at about 9 A.M we're
out there and I'm I'm uh up in the
rumble thing and on the other side of
the fence I see a bunch of cameras and
people and there's Larry Elder so at
first I was kind of I was sort of like
ah damn this sucks because it was as if
I found out I thought I found out that
Larry Elder was in the debate because I
see Larry Elder he's in Milwaukee he
must be in the debate so I think he's in
the debate it wasn't until a bit later
about an hour later where I found out
that he was not allowed in the debate he
is suing the RNC right now he is arguing
that he qualified meaning he had the 40
000 donors who at least put in
individual donors who at least put in a
dollar and then I think it's the way
they did it was there was like a net
aggregate of the polls that qualified
that he was at the one percent anyway it
was very pointing that it didn't happen
uh I did bump into Larry the next day in
the hotel and we chatted about it for a
bit and look Larry
Larry I don't think Larry believed he
was going to become president but Larry
on that stage communicating the ideas
you know Vivek is repeating a lot of
Larry's stuff about parenting and the
black community and all of that kind of
stuff in a two-parent household and the
lies about systemic racism Tim Scott is
hitting some of it the things that Larry
has been talking about and Thomas Saul
before him they're bubbling up and that
that's a great credit to Larry right and
he deserves credit for it and I'll
certainly always credit him for it and
I'll also always credit him for having
that incredible moment with me you know
eight years ago and causing my wake up
to so much of this stuff so I love the
guy he'll always be in the game you know
I don't think anything will really come
out of the lawsuit
um and and it's unfortunate because one
debate where he could have just got up
there and done it he deserves that cred
uh friends of Dave I like that name says
I want your opinion on a new approach
for the de Santa for DeSantis with his
campaign he needs to lean into his value
as a data nerd and not as an Entertainer
with over 20 years of experience this is
how he he decided to open the state
during coveted thoughts right so he he
went to the data he brought in latapo
our Surgeon General here he talked to
people like Jay bhattacharya who I've
had on the show many times he brought in
people like Brett Weinstein
um that is where he shines he shines I
think when the media is going after him
he shines when there's a hurricane which
again Ida comes last week and basically
the entire media machine and Trump too
despite Trump living in Florida would
have gladly taken
would have gladly had it been a bigger
hit on Florida if it would have damaged
DeSantis but nobody could even figure
out how to hit the Santas on this
because once again just like hurricane
Ian which is just about a year ago which
was basically a category five
um DeSantis basically did everything
right so your question basically is you
know on one hand you know he's trying to
be an Entertainer so you know he's
smiling a little bit more but as opposed
to just being the data nerd and the guy
who is just doing the stuff look I think
we got a good blend of that yesterday I
really do I think we got a good blend of
it yesterday as I keep saying to people
be patient it's early
the first votes will not be cast until
January but yes I think always leaning
into your strengths is a good thing and
that's also why I asked him and you
should watch the full interview if you
haven't it's like will you go on The
View will you do more of those combative
interviews because I think that's where
people will see boy he really can stand
up for himself not just explain it on an
obviously relatively friendly interview
with with say me or Megan Kelly but go
into the belly of the Beast and fight
those things he knows the data he knows
the numbers even the fact when I just
rifled off those bullet points that he
listed uh when he was giving me that
answer on how he's going to get the
Trump base I mean he basically listed
out like 15 things right off the top of
his head these are the things I've done
and as I said to you guys a moment ago
did he lie about any of this stuff no
it's all real
that's the case that needs to be made
Kathy says as you go off the grid year
after year does it get easier or harder
easier definitely like without question
it has gotten way easier over the years
you know the first year was just very
very weird because this idea of like
putting my phone in a safe and not
watching any TV and freaking out and
every now and again going into my pocket
like that was very weird a couple years
of that you know we've we're blessed
we've taken unbelievable trips to Bora
Bora and to to Mexican rainforests and
all over the place and you know really
figured out ways to disconnect
um I would say three years ago the first
year of covet is when it really got easy
because we were sort of locked at home
anyway we didn't go anywhere but it was
just kind of easy to just kind of lay in
the pool and and catch up on some
reading and not do much uh last year was
also a bit easier because Justin was
born so that just kind of like upended
our entire life and there was no time to
even think about what was going on in
the world uh and then this year was this
year was kind of easy because
life has settled in and it's good and I
know how to do this thing now and God
bless these guys that are in this room
with me like we were rebuilding the
studio the entire time uh and like I
knew everything was going to work one of
the great things that I have is I've
built out a team here where nothing
falls through the cracks I don't have to
worry someone's not going to show up one
day that the operation is going to
continue even if I'm not involved on the
day-to-day basis so it is it has gotten
way easier and I really recommend you
guys try it even if you just try it for
a weekend
like 99.9 percent of you that are
watching this when is the last time you
did not have your phone on a weekend
literally forget it 48 Hours 24 hours
when's the last time you tried it it is
worth it guys uh Larry says I know
everyone is interested in Pollock
politics
and to a lesser extent culture but what
about tying in the whole UFO situation
this issue has finally arrived at
Congress and no one is paying any
attention you know I don't know what to
make of this freaking thing I think that
there are so many like tricks in the
Shell game of the way the media and the
political establishment treat us right
now that on any given day they're like
oh the aliens are here we found
non-human biologics in a thing and it's
like well what the hell does that mean
non-human biologics what did a CAT enter
a spaceship and that crash like what are
we talking about and I think we're so
like for me and I love you guys no I
love sci-fi I love space I love all I
love aliens all that stuff
um like I'll be pretty happy the daily
aliens arrive you know
um I just to me unless we have like you
got to give me some freaking concrete
proof I I want independence day the
bunker somewhere in Nevada Will Smith
and the president and I want to talk to
this alien and then I'll start talking
about it a bit more for now I just think
it's a confusion I I and it's sort of
what covet is in a way it's just a
confusion from what's really important
right now and what's really important
government overreach what's really
important government censorship big Tech
censorship what's really important how
about ending this Ukraine war right
what's really important how about making
sure we know basic truths like boys or
not girls Etc et cetera so I like sort
of like on this side of my brain of just
like what's out there and like cool
stuff that I like thinking about of
course I love thinking about aliens and
all the Sci-Fi stuff and spaceships and
Star Wars about
but I think it's a distraction at the
moment uh and Colitis says hey Dave I
was wondering if you had any friendly
tips for starting a podcast I'm doing it
with a couple of friends how do you keep
your audience entertained and wanting to
come back for more well first off uh
congratulations on start the podcast as
of yesterday I am told that there are
more podcasts than people on planet
Earth so that will be the challenge uh
you know I'm lucky I started about 11
years ago I was kind of early in on all
of this uh before politics also became
our national sport so I was able to
build something in a time when when
there was sort of a need for it to be
built and then I think we've been able
to take it in new directions and
innovate all along the way uh I would
say look the only piece of advice that I
can give you is just say what you think
just say what you think it's almost the
same piece of advice I would give you if
you just asked me for the general piece
of advice a piece of advice related to
life say what you think don't hide what
you think think about what you think
like don't just say for the
purposes of saying it but like really
why do you think this thing why are you
saying it why are you the person that
should be saying it does this match up
with how your life is it won't always
but like really if you work through all
of that stuff and you start putting it
out there whether it's on rumble or
YouTube or locals or anywhere else
people will start finding it the other
just sort of like more granule piece of
advice is don't worry about the numbers
you cannot worry about the numbers like
you might put out five podcasts and
nobody watches but your mom you'll get
one view on each one
but you know what on podcast six you
might suddenly go boy 247 views on this
thing that's kind of interesting what
were we talking about that suddenly we
got a few more views and then you go oh
wow we got a thousand uh listens on this
one and then you start realizing oh
there's something happening you get kind
of in the algorithmic game and it is an
algorithmic game whether you like it or
not as I often tell you guys why do we
put content up in August it's not really
because I want to it's because if we
shut the channels down in August
completely we will be so far kicked out
of the algorithm that we will basically
spend three months catching up so
September for the last couple years we
lose a crazy amount of money it's it's I
view it as sort of a a sunken cost I
suppose we will lose a certain amount of
money because because we put up less
content in August and we're just
catching up to get back into the
algorithm the algorithm is just this
Wave It's or not this wave it's just
this like crazy stream that's going and
if you're not feeding that stream all
the time the tributaries dry up so you
got to keep feeding it so you get back
in
that's one thing at a time just say what
you think then we'll go from there uh
Florida mancock says regardless of who
the Republican nominee is how do you
think or how long do you think it would
take for any of the presidential
policies to actually start taking the
weight off Americans I'm concerned that
the last four years of damage has been
so severe that will it will take 10
years or more to undo that's a great
question look I think things can
actually happen pretty quickly you know
when Biden took over
well you know what I don't even want to
do that because it was so confusing
because of kobit and everything else
let's try to kind of do it in a blank
slate when generally speaking if you get
a competent president
who is exuding confidence who has a
track record and let's say believes in
capitalism let's just do this at the
economic level and Trump absolutely had
this why were the markets until Kobe
doing incredibly well under Trump well
he got rid of a little regulation for
sure uh he got rid of or he added some
tax breaks for sure and then what
happens is the machine itself starts
loosening up right banks are like oh
well there's less regulation tax rates
are going down people are spending a
little bit more money we can lend a
little bit more money interest rates go
down inflation goes down so you can do
it just by being someone that is thought
of as friendly
purely at an economic level you can do a
lot right at the beginning and I
actually think whether well I can't say
if it was Trump if this would happen
because the machine is so out of whack I
think for sure if it was DeSantis on day
one and people knew what his track
record is look at our flourishing
economy here in Florida with no state
income tax I think the economy would
start turning around I also think you
could do things very very quickly in
terms of foreign policy and this is
absolutely a credit to Trump right
everybody said all of these Middle East
peace Deals they were never going to
happen Trump was able to do them in just
you know a short few years like you can
turn things around pretty quickly but I
also think you're right to the extent
that you need years to do a lot of stuff
and you need stuff also you can't just
do something that can just be reversed
that's the problem
of doing everything by the pen right we
do everything by executive order and
then the next guy comes in and he does
it by executive order and then we just
rinse and repeat that's a great argument
also for DeSantis you want someone who
can be president for eight years so you
could have four years of really just
smashing the system draining the swamp
changing a lot of stuff and then four
years of really codifying that into the
system solidifying that so there you go
Amy Says did you have a first birthday
celebration for Justin and did he get
his own smash cake yes so for those of
you who don't know the smash cake is
when you let a kid
you put the cake in front of the kid the
kid doesn't know what to do and the kid
just beats the hell out of the cake
smashes it in the face everywhere so
first off we have two pictures here that
is the smash cake that we made and you
might be looking at that cake go and
that is a one that is a weird wild cake
uh my sister-in-law Kalyn who's also our
set designer here uh and has and has
done the very artwork behind me uh she
made that cake it was a hundred percent
healthy no sugar in it it's made out of
like yogurt and coconut oil and like all
of this stuff that is a hundred percent
good for kids and she added like even
the color in that is not that's not blue
dye it's I think it's made from pea
powder that you can somehow make blue
like craziness it was totally healthy
and we'll show you one picture you know
I don't show pictures of the kids uh on
the show or on social media but yes that
is just in smashing his cake and I
assume that's Luke's foot uh yes and he
smashed the hell out of it smashes it on
his face all I mean it was a freaking
mess Clyde ate most of the cake uh but
yes it was it was totally fun and the
fact that this kid is one already and
Luke will be one in just a couple weeks
it's it time goes freaking fast that is
one thing that has changed you know life
is
been good for me especially these last
couple years and Florida has been great
and everything else and we're building
stuff and I'm I'm doing stuff that I
love so life kind of moves fast but I
can tell you having these kids like it
has accelerated the speed that life
feels like it's flying by it's so fast
it's wild Chad says what was your
favorite part about being off the grid
this year uh well as I told you we were
we were in the Mexican rainforest
did nothing we did nothing we ate we ate
healthy like I for the month of August
and we weren't there for the entire
month but for the month of August we ate
right
I worked out every single day when we
were there we were in the spa I worked
out for an hour and a half a day or we
worked out for an hour and a half a day
and then we did the sauna Steam and cold
plunge have you guys done this cold
plunge thing we were going back and
forth between the sauna Steam and coal
punch for about an hour every day 10
straight days of that then just laying
out in the in the rainforest laying in
the beach as I said yesterday just kind
of purging some of the information from
my brain but I I ate right I exercised
right I was around some friends and some
family like I had a just an incredible
month being around the kids seeing the
kids when we came back it was the whole
package this year it really was and
again as I said when we came back you
know I thank you guys for that
especially those of you on locals like
you allow me to do these things and the
exchanges I will fight to the best of my
ability uh for the right principles to
keep this country in order John says
what's your opinion on using AI
generated images to deceive voters bad
bad bad and dangerous as hell and guess
what it's going to be happening more in
more and more look AI is it is in some
ways it is the final frontier of reality
as we know it you know for those of you
that are a certain age watching this
show if you're a gen xer like me you
know you're you're basically part of the
last generation
that knew the world before the internet
right I remember I was a sophomore in
college
the first time I saw the internet on a
computer where it had a color a color
screen and a picture right so for the my
freshman year of college and maybe in
high school I had an email address I
didn't know what email was it was a
random set of numbers I didn't know who
to send it to I don't think I ever used
it but I had this thing called an email
address
I remember sophomore year of college
Brock you'll appreciate this one
sophomore year of college I hear some
kids screaming down the hallway he's
like I'm on the internet I I'm on the
internet and a whole bunch of us running
this is at the dorm we run into his room
and I will not forget this on his
computer it had a Yankees logo and a
Royals logo and it said Yankees three
Royals two and it was on the internet
and he was freaking out and I remember
thinking this is the stupidest thing
I've ever seen like why wouldn't I just
watch ESPN later to find this out the
point is I'm not that old I'm 47 that
was 1995 1996 like the world is changing
so freaking Fast And now when you add an
AI the idea that the algorithms the
machines can come up with creativity it
is crazy that they can write scripts
they can they can come up with art I
mean the art the AI art that I've seen
some of it's incredible like you can put
in some of these AI algorithms you could
just put in some words so some things
you like okay I like baseball I like
coffee I like Dave Rubin it will come up
with coffee baseball Dave Rubin art and
it's pretty freaking good but that is
scary what does that say about the human
experience related to art like the
machines at what point did the machines
not need us right and that's why I
always reference The Matrix when the
machines we then become the problem for
the machine or you could watch
um you could watch almost any sci-fi
movie of all time uh when the machines
turn on in Terminator 2 right you could
watch iRobot when they just don't need
us anymore yeah Dave says did you go on
vacation with David if so how was it so
Dave is asking Dave a question about
Dave's vacation with David that's a good
one yes I I think we referenced that one
already uh and it was
quite spectacular uh Mitchell says any
thoughts on how you slash we can support
Jordan Peterson during his stay during
his stay at hotel re-education so we
referenced this the other day I talked
about it with Jordan in Milwaukee and
we'll have Jordan on to discuss this a
bit more but uh long story short you
want to get me a line on this to get so
I can get the specifics right basically
Jordan who was a uh he was a professor
at uh University of Toronto and he was
also a practicing clinician
of psychology he had a he had a full-on
psychology practice in Canada the the
governing board in Canada is trying to
remove his license and they literally
want him to go to a re-education camp in
essence I'm getting some info here from
the New York post controversial Canadian
psychologist Jordan Peterson has
launched a legal challenge against the
College of psychologists of Ontario
after he said the governing body
threatened to pull his practicing
license if he doesn't complete social
media re-education for comments he made
on Twitter and The Joe Rogan podcast so
they are literally trying to take his
license away now he doesn't have a
practice anymore meaning there he does
he's not seeing patients anymore but he
worked very hard as an undergrad and a
grad student and then as as a clinician
to have that license and they have no
right to take that away and he does have
a human right I believe to free speech
it is not protected by the first
amendment in Canada because they don't
have the First Amendment they have
different laws related to Speech but
it's an absolute food farce and
ridiculous Fiasco and uh and I would say
they don't know who they've messed with
because Jordan is the top Lobster and he
ain't gonna take it uh hey Dave this is
from Ben he says I'm a huge Star Wars
fan I love the prequels
OT clone wars and Rebels I overall have
a negative view on Disney Star Wars
content despite them occasionally
putting out stuff that I enjoy uh season
one of Mandalorian and the second
Anthology movies have you watched any of
the Ahsoka yet the Ahsoka series if so
would you recommend it or would my time
be better spent watching MASH reruns uh
I have not watched Ahsoka I do not have
Disney plus I'm guessing you've watched
it so good you you like
Brock likes this okay Brock does not
care about giving money to Disney sure
he takes money from Dave Rubin and then
he gives it to Disney we're gonna have
to have a sit down later you you don't
watch any of this trouble Phoenix does
not watch this stuff Connor what you
don't watch it either you don't he
watches the baseball uh yeah I have
heard decent things about Ahsoka but in
my estimation at this point you guys
know this Disney has so mucked it up I
don't want to support Disney as a
corporation anyway
um my hope would be that one day if for
some crazy reason George Lucas is I will
get back in for one year that he just
buys the franchise back at a discount
because Disney's stock is depressed and
everything else and they've so mucked it
up and fixes the whole thing so I have
no doubt I trust Brock like I'm guessing
Ahsoka is probably pretty good I just
can't deal with it like I didn't watch
Kenobi I did watch one or two clips of
Vader on Kenobi on YouTube like I just
don't want to support this thing anymore
I think it's deeply dangerous literally
I mean this it is dangerous for for two
or three giant corporations to own all
of our stories the Disney should not own
Star Wars and the Marvel Universe not
because there's anything wrong with that
at a business level it becomes at a
spiritual level like
corporations and and middle management
people and people that are are part of
the machine dreams should subvert the
machine and that's what Star Wars was
about that's that's George Lucas's
Legacy of Star Wars fighting the studios
to make Star Wars they wouldn't give him
enough money and he negotiated the
rights for all the little toys which
they were like no one's no boys are
going to play with little toys because
at that time in the late 70s it was only
girls that played with dolls and he had
the foresight to go no no we're going to
make action figures right there was
there was basically G.I Joe 20 years
before that the big ass GI Joes but that
was it and he said no I'll take the
licensing on this and then he turned
that into billions of dollars because he
was fighting the system the entire way
which is in many ways with the essence
of Star Wars the story is about then it
gets owned by Disney I think you get the
point I'll fight you naked that's an
interesting name says Dave if Trump wins
the low IQ people Riot and they trash
everything if they cheat enough for
Newsome to win the right protests and
gets called terrorists for complaining
is there any possibility of an outcome
where things don't get worse
how does it not get worse
how does it not get worse well look I
can give you the one that you're already
probably thinking
DeSantis winning
obviously everyone on the rights happy
does the left go bananas no matter what
when the left loses anything they lose a
Supreme Court decision they lose
whatever legal battle they're fighting
they lose an election do they go bananas
with everything are they just waiting to
unleash the next BLM in the next antifa
of course they are and how do you know
that well we've had Biden for a couple
years and suddenly antifa disappeared
and suddenly black lives matter
disappeared are we to believe that all
the issues that antifa cared about
whatever they were or whatever it is
that BLM cared about did any of that get
resolved no so that so those are the
foot soldiers for the Democrat Party
right so yes I believe that to some
extent if if a republican becomes
president you're going to get some
degree of violence but what I think
what I think you would get with DeSantis
is you would get you would get moral
Clarity you I think you would get legal
and political Clarity and that would
help
it wouldn't stop all of it but it would
it would
it would take a little of the energy
away from the craziness
um I do think you're right too and this
is one of the things where Trump is
really playing with fire if you keep
saying that the election was stolen
well you're basically saying they're
going to see in essence what he's saying
is not that they just did they steal
that one but they're going to steal this
one from me so everyone if you look at
the base people the hardcore base people
they already think the next election was
stolen by the way I don't think that's
completely out of the like that's not
like a completely insane thought in that
these are nonsensical indictments right
I'm not saying Trump didn't do anything
wrong but we know they're only going
after him because he's running for
president right if he would have just
and that's the really twisted part of
this if Trump just would have went off
into the sunset and supported DeSantis
DeSantis would be winning virtually
every Republican would be voting for him
half of the uh the Democrats who were on
the fence would have already moved over
Trump would be the king maker we could
have such freaking Unity right now
except for the wacky worksters
but Trump's not going in that direction
but the point is yes if you've already
said to the people they stole the
election last time from me they're in
essence stealing it this time will the
right then be out on the streets again
and will that cause it's a big mess it's
a big mess and I just would say uh the
best place you can live when it's a big
mess is not in a blue City because those
are the places that it's going to go
crazy uh Julian says love the new studio
what inspired you to design it this way
you know there's well first off I
appreciate that and I'm really thrilled
that that so many people are digging it
I love it I just think it's so beautiful
we wanted there were all sorts of things
that we wanted we wanted different
textures so you know we got some wood
and we got you know these Oak slats here
and we got these black slats here and we
got the marble here and I was involved
in every every single step of this from
putting the stuff on the shelves to
going to the store and picking out the
exact marble that we used one of the
things that's the coolest part of this I
mentioned this the other day
but it's worth repeating so these marble
slabs that you're seeing here these are
two by four each and they're completely
random so meaning you go to the store
and they don't put them out you don't
buy them as if they're a giant Mosaic uh
Kalyn who did this and who's also the
painter of this piece and designed the
whole set she hand painted the on top of
these so that it appears all to be one
piece I mean she's just unbelievably
talented we also by the way in case
you're noticing this right now we did
dim the lights on the shelves over here
a few of you people a few of you people
have mentioned that we should dim that
so we did that a little bit
um I I just wanted something that that
felt brighter and More Alive oh and I
should mention it's
kalenrosejanet.com which I mentioned
yesterday if you want a print of this or
some of the other artwork that's in my
house and this is a print by the way
that's not the original so if you want
to print just like that that you can get
that Kalin c-a-y-l-i-n rosejanet.com but
I'm really thrilled with this and really
more than anything else I can't wait
till you guys see the rest of the studio
we're just finishing a little portion
over here we're going to do there's the
side angle that I'm loving that side
angle how you doing over there how you
doing
um we're going to do lives in studio
guests here uh we have I think how many
we'll have four total camera angles
eventually or five even I think we might
even have five at some point
um yeah we're putting in a fifth Connor
get to it it's gonna be up there right
above you
um yeah I'm just psyched about what
we're doing here and I and I think it's
also it's good for me to be in a new
spot I think it's good for the team it's
good to reinvest in what you're doing
um you know I've never believed I've
said to this to you guys before I don't
believe in growth just for the sake of
growth I never wanted to grow the show
just so that we can get a few more
viewers so we can get a little more
money so we can hire more people like
just for the sake of that but I feel
like what we did here was we invested
you know a good chunk of change to do
something that'll inspire me to do
better work these guys do better work
hopefully more of you to tune in and
share it and show people you know so
many people it's interesting I was I was
like the first guy that had the the real
home studio that's that clip with Tucker
that I show do I was early in on that
you know everyone has it now because of
covet and everything else I was one of
the first guys to do that if not the
first probably the first to have the
full-on home studio like that then
everyone started doing smaller versions
of it and smaller versions and everyone
started doing just the the screen behind
them which virtually everyone is doing
and that's what we were doing upstairs
at my house here and I was like I just I
want to go back to something real and
authentic and and that's what we're
getting here and I'm glad that you guys
are digging it Elizabeth said are we
going to ever get common sense or
innovative solutions to problems or is
it really all about control and profit
so nothing will ever be solved in the
most intelligent and efficient way what
step can be taken to increase efficiency
in government well I would say to the
last portion of that
we get Innovation and efficiency in a
lot of things that have nothing to do
with government which is why you should
want less regulation I have no doubt
that you do and you would want lower
taxes and all the things you want the
government basically out of the way so
the individual human can exchange ideas
and goods and services with another
individual human and build great things
build great railroads build great tech
companies build whatever it might be
build infrastructure and everything else
right that's what you really want
I don't have great hope for the federal
government again I do think if there was
a chance at a political level it can be
fixed I think DeSantis is our last best
hope I just don't think Trump could do
it I don't I think too many people will
be afraid to work for him I think
there'll be too many distractions and
all of that stuff I'm sorry that's just
that's just how I feel and I think
there's a lot of evidence to bear that
out
um but I think if you got a government
well look you don't even have to listen
to me just look what's happening in the
country right now what are the states
that are flourishing where people are
moving to and good things are happening
where there's Law and Order and there's
sound economics and a low amount of
homeless people and everything else it's
the red states there are places that are
working and then just this morning we're
going to play the clip tomorrow Eric
Adams the mayor of New York gave a talk
this morning talking about how New York
City now because they became a sanctuary
city is getting 10 000 illegal
immigrants a month so illegal people who
are by definition illegal thus thus
criminals in that they're breaking the
law by being here New York City said
come on in now their homeless shelters
are overtaken they're giving them hotel
rooms the famous Roosevelt Hotel if I'm
not mistaken is now basically a migrant
shelter it's causing crime it's causing
property values to go down all of those
things people are fleeing New York City
and he basically said he doesn't see an
end to it the guy should be impeached
immediately he should be impeached for
what he's done but he should also be
impeached I don't know that you can
impeach someone for this but for not
giving people hope he basically said
there's nothing I can do it's going to
get worse we'll play the clip for you
tomorrow it's absolutely wild so you can
either live in a place like that or you
can find a place that believes in Law
and Order and all the other good things
that we talk about all the time
ladies and gentlemen that is our
Thursday program for today I have
several meetings and other things to
take care of we've got some
announcements probably coming next week
everything's good on this front tomorrow
we're back with the panel we have Alex
Stein from The Blaze and making her
Reuben report debut my friend Isabel
Brown will be here if you want to join
us for the post game show right now
reubenreport.locals.com and the full
interview with Governor DeSantis is up
on locals Rumble and YouTube we leave
you with the current president or at
least guy pretending to be president and
the former president who may or may not
be a crack smoking homosexual goodbye
I spent last summer going through the
black sections of my town holding
rallies in Parks trying to get black men
to understand it's not unmanly to wear a
condom I got tested for AIDS I know
Barack got tested for rage there's no
shame in being tested for AIDS
foreign
[Music]